what it do everybody my name is ross
panetta
chef and owner of five kitchen and today
we're here to test out four celebrity
french sauce recipes to see which one is
the best one
on today's lineup we have oprah winfrey
kylie jenner
jason derulo and my favorite restaurant
in the whole wide world the rock
i measured out the ingredients as each
recipe stated and i brought a few french
toast
fans to help me figure out which one is
the best recipe
so which celebrity has a frenchiest
toast stay tuned and find out
so first up we have oprah winfrey she's
going to start off by slicing her french
toast
toasting her coconut flakes in an oven
at 350 degrees in a mixing bowl we're
going to add eggs
sugar milk sour cream salt
vanilla and mix it all up once the
coconut flakes are done toasting we're
going to dip the bread in the egg
mixture and evenly coat it in the
toasted coconut flakes
in a pan we're going to melt some butter
and toast the french toast on both sides
until nicely golden brown
she's going to finish it off with maple
syrup powdered sugar and whipped cream
and there you have it oprah winfrey's
coconut crusted french toast
it looks really cute it's like sad but
tasty looking
it definitely looks like it's a coconut
crusted
french toast
delicious thick i like this one i do
like the texture how crunchy it is
it's not bad but i don't love it the
coconut adds a little crunch it's a
little chewy
you know it's really good i feel like
this immediately takes me like to a
beach
i would definitely recommend this to
somebody else coming in hot we got kylie
jenner in a mixing bowl we're gonna
combine eggs
milk cinnamon vanilla and we're gonna
beat that like michael jackson
in a ziploc bag we're gonna crush up
some frosted flakes to make some nice
little dust
we're gonna take each piece of bread and
dip it in our egg batter and coat it in
a frosted place
in a pan we're going to melt some butter
and we're going to toast it
on both sides until nicely crispy golden
brown in the pan she had some brown
sugar just for some extra added
sweetness
and to finish it off she tops it off
with some whipped cream and there you
have it kylie jenner's frosted flake
coated french toast
damn this one does not look like french
toast to me at all so i'm like kind of
weirded out
this looks like a moldy hash brown or
something
this seems like something i could easily
make at home it's like pretty simple
the crunchy outer side isn't really
doing it for me
very crunchy there's the cinnamon
it's very difficult to eat i like this
one better because it doesn't have the
coconut it's not bad i really like it i
would just add syrup
coming in third we got jason arullo in a
mixing bowl we're gonna put together a
standard french toast egg mixture but he
throws in a twist of coconut flake
in another bowl we're gonna put together
cap'n crunch berries froot loops and
lucky charms for a nice sweet rainbow
surprise
he crushes it all up and that is going
to be our coating
so he takes each piece of bread dips it
in our egg mixture and
coats it in our rainbow sugary cereal
mix
once each piece is coated in the sealed
mixture we're going to toast it on both
sides in the pan with some butter
we're going to top it off with some
maple syrup as if there's not enough
sugar on it
and voila there you have it jason
derulo's tic tac god french toast
ooh this one looks really fun it's like
rainbow
i'm here for this i'm definitely feeling
the vibe the rainbow crust here is
definitely like a fruity pebble
situation
i really do like the texture it's like
super crunchy tastes like little rocks
in a good way this is nice this is the
least sweet
of the french toast we've tried it's
good it kind of tastes like a classic
french toast with a little bit of a
crunch i'll probably eat this whole
thing if i was hungry and it's breakfast
but it's not my favorite french toast
i've ever tried
it's mostly just for show the color it
doesn't really add a ton of flavor
but i kind of like this if you don't
like super sugary french toast
this is a good option for you and the
recipe everyone's been waiting for
the rock we're going to start off by
cutting up four inches of our brio
spread
in a large mixing bowl we're going to
put together a massive amount of our
french toast egg batter
in a little bowl we're going to put
together his secret weapon tequila maple
syrup using taramona tequila and with
that egg mixture we're going to evenly
coat our four inch pieces of brioche
bread as evenly as possible
in a large pan we're going to toast our
large-ass pieces of french toast
to serve he tops it off with some peanut
butter jelly
and his tequila maple syrup do you smell
what the rock is cooking
i sure do this one looks super different
than your
normal french toast it's huge this is
fancy this looks like a 50 brunch french
toast i'm really excited about this i
love peanut butter and jelly let's dive
in
this one's super good damn who needs it
uncrustable
this is the not so much french toast
but definitely a solid peanut butter and
jelly sandwich this is the kind of
french toast i think
you would order at like a fancy fine
dining brunch place
let me take another bite
out of these four celebrity french toast
recipes my favorite has to be number one
i love the coconut crust i thought it
was perfectly moist
it still felt like a traditional french
toast
oprah of course it's oprah out of the
four
french toast that i've tried number four
is definitely my favorite
it looks super fancy like the kind of
french toast you would pay
like 15 for oh
[Music]
i didn't even know he had recipes so out
of these four
celebrity french toast recipes i have to
say my favorite is number one
i think it had the best combination of
texture and
flavor without being too showy like some
of the other ones
oh bro love that
yes and there you have it oprah has the
best french sauce recipe
i think everyone is gonna get a french
toast you get a french toast and you get
a french toast because oprah winfrey
takes today's
celebrity french toast challenge which
one of these celebrity recipes was your
favorite
leave a comment below
[Music]
so
[Music]
you